So today we've talked about meta-reasoning. This very strongly leveraged and
built on nearly everything we've talked about so far in this course.
Meta-reasoning is, in many ways, reasoning about everything we've covered so
far. We started off by recapping learning from correcting mistakes and
the related notion of gaps. Then we covered two broad metacognitive techniques
called strategy selection and strategy integration. We then discussed whether or
not meta-meta-reasoning might exist. And
we decided, ultimately, that such a distinction isn't even necessary. After all,
the structures involved in meta-reasoning, like cases, and
rules, and models, and the same as those involved in a reasoning,
itself. So, meta-reasoning is already equipped to reason about itself. Finally,
we discussed a particular example of meta-reasoning, called goal-based autonomy.
Meta-reasoning is in many ways the capstan of our course.
It covers reasoning of all the topics we've covered so far, and
it provides a way that they can be used in conjunction with one another.
We do have a few more things to talk about though, and
we'll cover those in our Advanced Topics lesson.